been 24 suicides within the clark county  school district since the beginning of  the pandemic lilia luciano reports teens  and young adults are struggling with  loneliness feelings that they don't  belong and tonight she meets with a  local teacher who motivates his students  with messages  you matter you are loved you are never  alone my heart's red super giant for you  all in search and then  well the subject of suicide hits home  for him the his 18 year old brother is  included in that number anthony orr took  his own life in august of 2020. cbs news  correspondent lilia luciano with an  important story see her eye on america  report tonight on the cbs evening news